how hard is it to win the main event of
the World Series of Poker
so the main event of the World Series of
Poker is the hardest event to win simply
because of the sheer size of it you know
you're talking seven eight thousand
players right and a lot of landmines and
and frankly
there are so many players that you've
not played with before too you play
these high roller events like the super
ones you get 30 40 people you know
everybody right so you have an idea
you sit at the main event there's you
don't know have any idea this guy
wearing a Philadelphia Eagles jersey and
sunglasses and you just raised you big I
don't know I don't know this guy I don't
know what he's about so there's a lot of
like
it's grueling too in your seven eight
days where you're you're in the blender
as you as you might say so so what's the
structure says ten thousand dollar
buy-in or something like that and
there's a bunch of tables and you just
keep playing as and you like when is it
over for a single table
so the way that it works is this so
there's let's say 8 000 players and the
way the main event Works unique to
others is there's various day ones you
can play right so Day One You're Gonna
Play from noon to like midnight right if
you if you're still in you bag up your
chips and you'll come back for day two
okay there's four different day ones
right now they'll all combine
essentially to play on a day too and at
the end of the night they redraw the
tables so you don't just win your table
if players get knocked out tables break
they continue to be replaced so you
start with a thousand then you know
after day one you've got six thousand
then you do the same you play you know
like 12-hour day and you slowly Whittle
down day four day three day four you're
in the money and then you continue to
progress and then what they do now with
the final table is they they because
they were trying to do this for TV these
final tables can take
you know 12 hours to play and what we
were finding was
you know you start to think at 5 pm and
it goes till 8 A.M and like nobody's
watching anymore so they separate
separated into three days now
and so you're talking now
it's like six seven days to get to the
final table another three days to play
it so you're under you know you're
you're grinding for
you know week and a half but most of the
time
you're playing against people you've
never played against before especially
early on yeah and then by the end like
who knows you know rarely do you see
100 you usually see some notable names
then in the last 27 you might see one
maybe two final table maybe one but
often it's gonna be you know some
players you've never heard of before is
there strategies that
maximize your likelihood of having a
chance yes absolutely like I think the
World Series of Poker main event is a
unique animal in that you know like we
talk about Game Theory and all that kind
of stuff if you're focused on that when
you're playing you're really not playing
well right you need to just exploit
because you're going to have a lot of
people who see this as a bucket list
item you know they just want to play the
main event in the World Series and they
might be scared they might be nervous or
whatever you don't have to worry about
being balanced right oh you know I have
to make sure that I'm about no you don't
you might know you're playing with this
guy now for three hours you might never
see him again so just make the play that
makes sense for you right so
so yeah you're gonna I approach that
event very differently than I would like
playing against the High Roller players
that I play with does that mean more
aggressive essentially less actually
so when you play against really good
players you have to take
small plus EV scenarios where you push
the envelope and you're playing really
aggressive you're bluffing off your
stack you got to do this you gotta focus
a little bit more on being balanced
because otherwise you know you're not
going to beat these guys whereas if
you're playing with amateurs and you're
playing with regular players for the
most part
risking all your chips on a bluff
probably don't need to do that you don't
need to do that nearly as much you can
probably
slowly but surely build your stack
without taking you know those high risk
High variant situations because you'll
find better situations
what uh mistakes do amateurs usually
make
in tournaments like that are they over
bluffing well I think amateurs generally
the biggest mistake they make is they
think that Pros are bluffing more than
they are
so like a pro will bet all his chips on
the end they're like I don't know
it's Phil Ivey maybe he's doing some
crazy stuff he's like probably not yeah
he's probably just got it you know and
then they get lose all their money by
calling or going all in as well
um
and so the right things to be more
patient for so amateur is too impatient
well also bad reads so all the amateurs
are built different some of the amateurs
are just too weak and passive they're
just waiting for the nuts you know yeah
and then you know the pros everyone
notices that and then when they make
their big hand they don't get paid
anyway so in order to win the main event
I mean you have to have some components
of your game that are aggressive it's
very unlikely to expect to just get the
cards the whole way and just always have
the best hand you're gonna have to find
ways to win pots that you know where you
don't have the best hand how do you win
the Final Table the final table is
unique now especially because you're
talking about the way that poker Works
in tournaments is that if there's seven
people left and you have just you know
you're very short on chips but if one
other player goes out you just make like
three hundred thousand dollars for
folding like just for sitting out right
the term for that that you know
kids use is ICM independent you know
chip model right where it talks about
the value of each chip where what
happens what we see now is let's say one
guy has a big chip lead
and there's another guy who's second in
chips and there's a couple that are
short these guys in the middle
they just play super tight and they wait
for the little guys to go while the big
stack is just
pounding them because he can afford to
right he knows that people are
handcuffed so let's say I had 10 million
in chips and you have 9 million chips
and these guys have little chips if I go
all in on you are you gonna call me
and risk like you know guaranteed pay
jumps of like moving up a few spots so
really the question comes down to like
are you the type of guy who just wants
to inch up or are you gonna go for it
and you're gonna go for the win I think
ultimately there's some value in being
the guy who says you know I don't care
if I come seventh I'm not worried about
going from Seventh to fifth I'm here to
win and so you're saying like the the
guys that win will often be the ones
that call there so like they're not just
bullying the small Stacks they're well
they're the ones no they're the ones
that are willing to willing to risk it
right so there are some people who you
know if there's
five left
you know and they're third in chips and
there's two guys very short and you you
know they'll have Ace King and someone
moves it they'll just fold they fold the
hand because they want to wait for those
two other players to get broke and that
way they let you know they make actual
money so you I guess the thought process
between winning first place and winning
the most amount of money are different
they're conflicting right because in
order to like when if you're just if
your focus is only on winning the
tournament you will make mistakes
financially where you had guaranteed
income for just folding right let's say
a guy has one chip left you know one
chip and me and you have good chips and
I go all in with you and I lose now that
guy you know got the guaranteed you know
he got the pay jump that I wouldn't have
got so there's some extremely stupid
mistakes you can make from a financial
perspective but it's often at odds with
you know giving yourself the best chance
to actually come first
and in a tournament especially the main
event especially the final table it's
all about coming in first well I know
because most of the people who make it
so like you know when you play these
high rollers these guys are accustomed
to playing for a hundred thousand two
they're accustomed to this kind of money
so they're gonna play right for the most
but you're talking about guys who bought
into a ten thousand dollar tournament
maybe never had 100K cash in their life
and now they're sitting there and it's
like one million for fifth and 2 million
for fourth
so like they don't want to be fit
they're just gonna sit there and go ah
so they'll they'll be under more
financial pressure because they're not
like your typical high roller type
player are you still able to uh find the
guts to take big risks yeah see I'm
trying to win like I think that gives me
an advantage frankly where I might make
decisions that are financially
sub-optimal
because I'm trying to win but there's
also an inherent advantage to that like
that again something I've watched and
learned from a guy like Michael Adamo
where he takes advantage of these people
playing so passively in these spots
where he's like I don't I'm not trying
to come I'm gonna win I'm just gonna
bully bulldoze you because I'm not
worried about you know the small
Financial mistake of you know a pay jump